[Music]
in sad times new song submitted by bacon
lover I'm sorry two teenagers harmed a
teacher and several other young students
during a knife attack at school
what the [ __ ] two students had the knife
attack two teenaged senior students were
attacking younger kids as young as ten
is this a kung-fu school this is in
Russia that makes sense
same thing I think why so it seems like
these kids uh seventeen-year-old and is
a friend which I'm not sure how old he
is but apparently these two guys they
were fanatics of the Columbine massacre
shooting their copycats yeah that's all
oh don't you become a fanatic of a
massacre well losers like losers
I think um what is it the dude that did
the killing in Santa Barbara
the other thing thing was he was also
funny at Columbine shooting really set
off like a chain of events but it
inspires the losers all together like
refresh people of what the Columbine
[ __ ] is cuz that was a while ago yeah
it's really oh there were 12 students
and a teacher that was were slaughtered
by two teenage students that came in
during school and just started blasting
near the trenchcoat guys
yeah effect in 1999 April 20 they called
trenchcoat mafia I think that was the
name of their crew trenchcoat mafia or
something like that they that happened
when I was in high school oh yeah I
remember when it happened it hasn't been
saying a lot of crazy [ __ ] happened in
high school 9/11 happened in high school
[ __ ] really yeah Columbine happened
like when we were freshmen 99 with
Columbine right that happened first
right yeah all I'm saying is a lot of
crazy stuff happened when we were in
high school
9/11 happened dude imagine the kids of
today they can it ain't even that crazy
it's like
there they're having Columbine should
happen every other week that song that
is crazy and their friends are eating
Tide Pods and [ __ ]
that is pretty crazy alright recording
condoms and [ __ ] it's a weird world that
was like - all sorry I'm not hip I don't
understand these things yeah what what's
going on with the world yeah so these
kids they just started they went into
the school they went into a chemistry
class and then just started stabbing
people and now apparently like witnesses
are saying that they were stabbing in
silence if they weren't seeing anything
oh my being kids little kids in the neck
and then there's one teacher oh my gosh
one of the guys and then because of her
pushing on them distracted him and some
kids were kids were able to oh whoa here
oh yeah but right now she's in serious
condition in the hospital so that you
can't even hear a stab - no it's not
like you know the movie it's worse like
you know it's awesome
yeah it's like the you ever hear noise
when something cuts into a steak nothing
only mmm you don't even make those
noises when we're having sex
yes I do I've been doing it but that
steak no you can't compare steak to you
come on I heard I'm kidding you're way
better than a ribeye steak
did you see the ribeye steak the main
suspects his name is Len he's 17 and he
was the one that pretty much it seems
like he's just attention the [ __ ] how
did you get a weapon like that that is
like a joke oh yeah yeah why does he
look like a thug thugged-out filthy
Frank yeah so apparently he was called a
dog online and that sparked oh that's it
it looks like a Malibu's Most Wanted
character
yeah yeah then this is uh the theme oh
my god I'm so sad he's being arrested
while they were attacking other people
stabbing these kids the two suspects
ended up getting in a fight as well like
somehow like they send each other it's
sort of fighting each other why you're
not stabbing the way I want you to stab
you shut up Wow
and then also the kids were saying that
they came in with knives and that just
like any regular kitchen knife there
were hunting things oh they were big
they're like buck knives
that's suck anyone died uh so far not
not acknowledged you know what I gotta
say though there's some pretty motivated
killers cuz it's really cold out there
and what is gloomy and cold you don't
want to do anything yeah you gotta wake
up move past that emotion yeah there was
blood all over the school
I rather deal with the shooter than
someone with a knife hell yeah
really should die instantly yeah and you
can because like you like you have more
chances against a shooter then someone
with a knife because they have to have
really good [ __ ] aim I just have to
throw people in front of me but
sometimes with knives I feel like you
know a lot of people survive because
they actually don't have full committal
you know when you're going for slashing
horses a gun even if you suck at
shooting a gun if it hits you you're
pretty much dead you know versus a knife
your your slash personal - yeah I don't
know about that yeah teacher thank you
teacher mm-hmm yeah but it's crazy I'm
so glad that they were able to be
arrested and there were no other harm
but then a lot of people are looking at
the situation saying like why were why
was it up to the kids to like stop this
these people like how did they even get
into the school and the freezing okay
that's cool no no cuz they're older
right yeah they're seniors okay there's
so many kids like have you like we've
all been to school and when they like
when you have to go to your class like
you're not really paying attention to
anything that's true
yeah but they were saying that this
school has guards like what happened to
the guards like why were there's not
enough I used to visit my girlfriend at
her high school all the time and I
didn't go
there I just have to find that sign it's
going to they're pretty they're pretty
serious about it because I try to visit
my old high school and right when I got
on campus
well hello [ __ ] soup do a pole dances
party rattling well I went there and it
was just like they're like where's your
past I was like first of all I'm older
than you
don't talk to me like that what I wonder
if Russia has the same kind of dangers
that we do in their schools so they
don't even know I'll even look for she
like yeah it cuz like my friend lived in
was it Brisbane California which is like
a small town in near San Francisco and
that [ __ ] look people could just walk in
and now it's not like our schools our
schools are just super guarded yeah my
high school used to be able to walk in
and out - not anymore it's all gated up
all gated up no lockers no nothing it's
like damn dude you guys have [ __ ] up
so bad that they can't even give you
regular people so your school is now a
prison it's ridiculous other towns
around the states when you're a senior
you can you can go off campus to get
lunch or whatever that's that's what
happened with our high school like we
used to be able to do that well I mean
when I got there like it was no more but
when it was my brothers year they were
able to go off-campus to get lunch and
then come back but then they just passed
this rule at that school that like oh no
off-campus lunch you have to eat lunch
they use care about the rules you have
to just do that in the in the 90s which
was beyond my time because I am much
much younger than that and there was a
drive-by shooting and then that's when
they had lockdown yeah cuz a rival gang
came to our school and just like when
lunch broke and everyone was walking
outside they started shooting at the
kids ya see I think in in the minority
community we have things like that but
it's like gang violence and then like
why people just have mass murderers yeah
so it's like no one's safe you could go
to a nice little town and it's like a
nice little white neighborhood and you
have guys that come in and shoot up the
whole school yeah but if you live in a
ghetto or whatever it's like you're
still not safe cuz you just have gang
violence and stuff that's so scary too
and you know
we get older I think like we start to
gain like a certain amount of empathy
and I think about these parents like
they send their kids off to school
everything is fine and then literally
from 8 a.m. till 4 p.m. you'll never see
your kid again yeah and you get this
crazy phone call that's I'm putting my
kids in school [ __ ] that are you paper
clip is gonna be awesome you're gonna
put your kids at school yeah yeah you
guys crazy they're gonna pick up some
badass social skills uh uh mm-hmm not
mine oh how is your kid gonna be yeah a
lot you know what you know it's crazy a
lot of my family members they're
homeschooling their kids but the way
they get social skills is like there's a
there's a homeschool program where you
can actually meet a goal yeah it's like
a school with other homeschool kids and
then that's where they make their
friends and all that stuff and there's
also like more time to do activities so
they make friends in their gymnastic
class and their swimming class in their
karate class or whatever yeah didn't we
talk about some school recently where
this like teenager he came up with this
school she's got one thirteen year old
on TED Talks yeah that's a it's a
special skew yeah oh my god there's two
hands on parenting I don't like that
[ __ ] I don't want to be involved in my
kid's life like that awesome cuz it's
like you are gonna be a great putter
no no joke though it's like you cuz
that's a full-time job homeschool the
kid is a full-time [ __ ] job because
it's not your job it's your wife's job a
friend of mine she's Mormon and she had
a lot of kids and she homeschools all
the kids and I see but she she right
you've got a do-nothing Hey fine if
that's the game that's mine I'm just
thinking about cuz for her she has to
learn the curriculum herself yeah she's
learning with the kids constantly
everything all over again it's a
full-time so on top of being a mom just
be a full-time teacher too
that's true that's pretty hard it's
relearning all the subjects exactly so
it's it's not easy and you have to do
that through all the way till they're
[ __ ] 18 so you're relearning an
insane amount of patience just to even
help Isaac with his homework Casey and I
are like oh my god
yeah not thinking like peasants who said
you had to do the work just hire a bunch
of mentors and then just have them come
to yours made you like build lockers
yeah and you build a school in your
house spread out PE uniforms yeah flash
and also is that it's just high school I
didn't want my kids are going to school
now yeah I just built the school my home
now got drug sniffing dogs all over
miles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]